fin de ce discours 1 devant koré
emmanuel macron l'a débuté par un mea
culpa plutôt étonnante sa part il a dit
je sais que je ne réussis pas tout
qu'est ce qui a échoué
non il a il a dit qu'il ne pouvait pas
qu'on ne pouvait pas tout réussir et
c'était simplement la marque d'une forme
d'humilité de l'homme qui malgré je
dirais le le tout le respect qui est dû
à sa fonction de président de la
république est bien peu comme être
parfois des erreurs ou en tout cas peut
ne pas toujours avoir raison
alors que c'est le reproche qui lui est
fait souvent que de ne pas savoir bien
écouter les autres il a commencé par
dire qu'il est qu'ils pouvaient tout à
fait le faire c'était simplement aucun
échec pendant cette première année du
quinquennat
vous savez évidemment qu'il y aura des
politiques publiques qui ont été mises
en oeuvre des réformes qui ont été
engagées qui ne porteront pas leurs
fruits
et d'ailleurs mais emmanuel macron quand
il était candidat ne s'en est pas caché
puisque c'est lui même qui a dit que
l'évaluation et le contrôle de nos
politiques publiques seraient au coeur
de l'exercice démocratique et donc tout
ce que nous faisons nous allons
l'évaluer et ce qui marche bien nous
l'amplifier rang ce qui ne marche pas et
bien nous les corrigerons